foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday January 24th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
on Monday Microsoft announced a
multi-year multi-billion dollar
investment in open AI the maker of the
chat GPT and Dolly applications the two
companies already had a partnership and
last week Microsoft's CEO Satya Nadella
said his company plans to incorporate
openai software into a range of its own
products from Microsoft designer to the
search engine Bing that is seen as a
Potential Threat to Google which has
dominated the search market for over a
decade so how could the use of AI change
online search as we know it and what
does this mean for the Market's players
joining me to discuss how this rivalry
could play out is our heard on the
street columnist Dan Gallagher hi Dan
nice to have you with us thank you for
having me so Dan I want to talk about
Microsoft's investment but first there's
been a lot of talk about how Ai and chat
GPT in particular is going to upend
search as we know it why do Observer
think there's this potential there well
I think because one it's such a new
thing when people started testing this
when it launched in late very late
November it was cool it was different
you know you type in this any kind of
question it gives you a very
conversational answer and so I think
Google was the immediate comparison
because often when we're trying to find
something on the Internet or find
something out we're Googling something
hey how do I do this how do I do that
and so having this tool that spit back
stuff that was like a lot more
digestible conversational seemed a
threat to that it made the Google search
seem old by comparison this is like an
existential threat to them was a kind of
fast interpretation I think so Microsoft
already had Partnerships with open AI
can you tell us about what their
existing relationships were and now what
this new investment is well I think the
new investment essentially just deepens
what they had and it's I read it as
something that Microsoft hasn't bought
the company outright but has got you
might say major dibs on the technology
that open AI has developed but I think
what this does is one it really
solidifies open ai's technology onto
Microsoft's Cloud infrastructure Azure
and that's a big deal for Microsoft
because they want those workloads and
want Azure to be front and center for AI
and it gives Microsoft these options I
mean what Satya Nadella said at Davos
last week is that they want to embed
this technology not just in Microsoft's
web search they have a competing product
to Google but they want to embed it
across all their Tech all their products
so theoretically Word and Excel and all
these things Microsoft has this so then
what does that tell us about the way
Microsoft in particular is viewing the
potential of this AI well they obviously
view it as like X expansive for
everything they have not just oh maybe
we can take some share from Google and
search I think they see it as this can
revolutionize all of our products all of
our services if we do it right so we
know how Microsoft
Google react
it's reacting to this investment but how
is it reacting to the you know explosion
of interest in chat GPT and open AI well
I think they're worried about it and
fairness Google has not been dead on AI
or they've invested a lot of money in AI
on their own over the years built it
into their data centers they've really
for years built themselves as like AI
first company but I think when chat gbt
came out and all of a sudden there was
this interest in it reportedly there
were Google inside Executives were
calling it a code reader we haven't seen
anything announced by the company like
any major transaction or change they're
doing but I think definitely they're
paying close attention but to go back to
what we were talking about before I mean
when you Google something when you
search it you don't always put in the
same kind of questions that people have
been putting into chat GPT I'm not
Googling can you write me an essay on
Dickens which some people have been
putting into chat GPT so is it really an
existential threat to what Google does
into its business model at the moment I
think that existential threat was
probably overestimated especially in the
near term because you're right there's a
janky term called monetizable search
that you know I mean Google makes most
of its money through search ads but not
every search especially not every query
put in chat gbt really works that way if
you ask chat gbt that okay can you
explain for me String Theory it'll give
you this very conversational answer
but it's not gonna that's not a revenue
generating answer and the other problem
with it is it gives you a single answer
and you know you when you search in
Google you get all these options you
know where it's coming from you can kind
of evaluate a is this good information
maybe not so good
Chad gbt has already been shown that
sometimes the information is speaking
out is not accurate and you can't really
tell where it's coming from so it's
maybe not as obvious a revenue generator
what does that mean for kind of cost
overall and for the cost of adding these
AI tools into existing products what's
Microsoft going to face when it does
that it's significant because just the
computing power to run a chat gbt search
versus a Google search has been
estimated to be like seven times as much
you know and that's just because under
the hood of this stuff is these data
centers with these like really expensive
chips and memory that have to do this
and the power consumption that comes
from that so I think is Microsoft embeds
more of this into its products and more
across its Network it'll face that
Google's gonna face it too because
they're clearly going to seek to keep up
with Microsoft so I think it's both
companies are kind of in a bit of an
arms race in this area they're going to
see their costs go up what does it mean
for the cost per query evaluation that
search engines have to make when they're
building their products well when a
company like Google is building
developing a search engine and refining
it clearly their first priority is let's
make this good information that gets
people to what they want to do and that
means they're going to keep coming back
and using it so if the world moves more
to users wanting you know AI in their
results Google's going to have to keep
up Microsoft's going to keep up and
that'll raise their cost of it and the
timing of this right now and the reason
this is kind of a relevant point is that
we're seeing these companies actually
worried about their costs overall all
right that's our Herd on the street
columnist Dan Gallagher Dan thanks so
much for joining us thank you for having
me and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas
for The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
foreign
[Music]